good morning Willie do you guys want to
see a trick pic of a bad person but
you're gonna be a great father good
morning Hank
good morning John today we're gonna talk
about Christmas cause it's Christmas
time it's almost Christmas time I feel
like the holiday season is upon us like
literally like like his preying upon us
it is latched on like a zombie
yes rolling our every movement certainly
controlled my movements in the last 48
hours because all I've done is buy stuff
Willie I'm sorry about the panic he
doesn't care he's forgotten about it
yeah that's the great thing about having
a dog it's a great thing about having a
stupid dog for Willie he's so beautiful
but he's so stupid Willie will you be in
the thumbnail oh don't know Hank and I
are both huge fans of the Christmas
season is that fair to say that's fair
to say
I hate it I love it I usually hate it
but this year have gotten more into it
because we're expecting our first kid
and you're here and Katherine's here and
mom and dad are here and we've got this
beautiful Christmas tree because I'm so
into Christmas this year I thought that
it would be appropriate to talk some
Christmas facts do stick ulation now
what was the first state to recognize
Christmas as an official holiday in the
United States I think it was Alabama
it's almost like I already told you this
fact and you're cheating
but when John when in 1838 the state of
Alabama declared Christmas a state
holiday Christmas did not become a
national holiday in the United States
until 1870 so for almost the first 100
years of our Union Christmas was not
considered a national holiday but early
in American history there were fewer
national holidays right but also we were
busier right people had stuff to do
that's like inventing electricity but
then they had their evenings off due to
lack of light do you know anything about
hot cockles hot cockles is not for
contemporary life okay so one person is
blindfolded they're a bunch of people in
the room and then one of the people who
isn't blindfolded it's the person who is
blindfolded and then the blindfolded
person has to guess who hit them so if
you want to be sneaky about it you're
like oh that was Sarah
that was definitely Sarah for some
reason associated almost exclusively
with Kristen why is it
and cockily what are you doing John did
you know that Rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer was invented by the Woolworth
company I did not know that because it's
not true
it was Montgomery Ward I should do the
facts Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer was
invented in the late 1930s by the
Montgomery Ward department store they
had one of their coffee writers a guy
named Robert Mays write a Christmas
story and because he was like a nerdy
wimpy small guy he decided to write a
Christmas story about a nerdy wimpy
small reindeer named Rudolph and then
this story just became massive because
everybody loves a nerdy reindeer if
you're gonna have a reindeer you want a
nerdy one in Canada
what is Santa's postal code I don't know
what a Canadian postal codes look like
letter number letter number letter
number is it leet speak it is leet speak
is it H yeah H zero
yes h0h 0h0 okay I got one
jingle bells yes you know how that goes
jingle bells Batman smells Robin laid
before it was about Batman it was about
what Christmas Thanksgiving no way
really Thanksgiving song which is why it
has no references to Christmas in it are
you sure yeah I'm gonna check that I'm
gonna fact-check Wow wrote it in 1857
for Thanksgiving program James Boyd Lord
Pierpont best known for composing jingle
bells but I mean to be fair he should be
famous for that beard alright Hank
here's the last Christmas back for you
do you know all of the words to the
jingle bells Batman smells song I think
I do
jingle bells Batman smells Robin laid an
egg the Batmobile lost a wheel and Joker
got away hey
happy holidays puff fight fight ow
puff is stronger than your puff